what is the thing that you did that I
find completely insane you know I was
the biggest game runner in New York City
they sent this guy to my apartment who
put a gun in my mouth the feds had put a
confidential informant in my games one
of my poker dealers said the FBI's here
looking for you our next guest was
dubbed the poker princess
you live a life where you don't want to
go through that again but you're glad it
happened
please welcome Molly Bloom she started
the world's most exclusive underground
poker tournament when the FBI shut it
all down Molly Bloom you actually were
willing to take accountability I needed
to take accountability I hated myself
and I didn't want to fight for myself
anymore and this like almost delusional
confidence that I'd always had was gone
that was one of the best conversations
that I've had on a podcast if not the
best